meagan Markel seemingly has babies on
the brain
the former suit star hinted at her and
Prince Harry's plans for starting a
family at an event on Friday
the couple toured the campus of Northern
Ireland's next generation Science Park
where they met a husband and wife team
who make innovative baby products that's
when the 36 year old told reporters
quote I'm sure at some point we'll need
the whole lot and earlier this week
royal expert Katie Nichol told ET that
Meghan isn't the only one thinking about
having children my sources are saying
that Prince Harry particularly is very
keen to start a family you know pretty
soon after the royal wedding he's he's
made no secret about wanting children
after the two announced their engagement
in November
Harry dished to the BBC about starting a
family with his leading lady children no
no currently no no of course you know
that I think you know one fit one step
at a time and we'll start a family the
lovebirds are set to marry at Windsor
Castle on May 19th
in front of a whopping 600 guests and on
Thursday Kensington Palace released a
photo of the regal invites
[Music]